growing up Mormon growing up in the LDS
Church being Mormon I felt like being
gay just wasn't an option
we were about as evil as a thing can get
the church hasn't really acknowledged us
I was ultimately told to suppress it I
dealt with a lot of self-hatred I
thought about suicide a lot
Utah's problem is that our suicide rate
has been climbing in youth and that's
appalling these kids are being lost but
there's no discussion in the church as
Mormons we need to have some serious
discussions and look in the mirror and
figure out what we're doing wrong the
church has made it fairly clear where
they stand on gay relationships and so
if you can't get on this ship those of
us that are in the trenches are gonna
make it happen and that's what Mama
dragons do
it's very cool to see this grassroot
network of women giving people hope and
giving people answers in the book how to
be a perfect Mormon mother there's no
chapter how to parent your gay kid
mama dragons is helping to write that
chapter
[Music]
before my son came out I felt like being
gay was an abomination
I felt like it was a choice I didn't
really ever question anything I was
asked by my leaders to canvas my
neighborhood and get signatures to
protect the marriage between man and a
woman and I was a good little soldier my
whole thought process changed when my
son came out Mormons tend to be a pretty
conservative Bunch
socially and current Mormon doctrine and
policy really doesn't have a place for
our LGBT kids a lot of people are
fearful that having their LGBT kids will
impact their relationship with the
church it may impact their standing with
the church they're not willing to reach
out and go to the next step
for a lot of Mormon moms having a kid
come out is the start of a real faith
crisis for them
Mondragon's is a support group for
Mormon moms with LGBT children one of
the things it does is help moms not feel
alone not feel like they're the only one
wine that bath we figured out that
Grayson molest transgender when he was
16 about halfway through his junior year
of high school I was you know supportive
of his transition but for about the
first year and a half I didn't know a
single other Mormon mom with a
transgender kid I don't want other moms
to feel alone as I felt in five years 10
years at the mama dragon still exists
we're gonna have a huge base there's
usually 10 to 15 every week that we add
so that's 60 new women a month so 720 a
year most mama dragons that I work with
and know have their finger and their
Poltz on at least 15 kids talking
through how they might be able to come
out to their parent or how to handle
their situation with their parents part
of that is is you know trying to help
with suicide prevention understanding
we're saying oh no that's not gonna
happen on my watch
[Music]
you know an average of 557 utah's died
by suicide every year it is the leading
cause of death in youth ages 10 to 17 in
Utah
no one is acknowledging that our LGBTQ
people feel so ostracized by the
religion that they're raised in here by
default if you don't fit in your church
community you then don't fit into your
neighborhood and then you don't fit into
your school the data is very clear about
young people who don't have a good
support network in particular young
people who feel rejected by their
families are at much higher risk we have
to change our whole culture about how we
treat LGBT young people in the church
[Music]
it meant a lot of Mama dragons because I
went and met them for lunch and then I
told him about the group and asked them
if they wanted to be a part so meeting
with them on one on one
and letting them share anything they
want to share
Anna was afraid to come out to us before
she came out she was telling us there's
a kid at school who's gay and he's being
bullied but it's like that was her and
she was afraid to tell us that mm-hmm
she was testing the waters you know what
I mean it's like if you know where my
parents gonna say well don't hang out
with that kid stay away from that kid
you know it makes me sad she slept in
the floor of our bedroom for a month you
know it's like I couldn't leave her
alone and knowing there are people like
Alison you know who
experienced our worst nightmare
Stockton was my long-awaited boy he was
the happiest kid spoiled rotten I would
say Stockton was very comfortable with
being gay
I think Sutton was very uncomfortable
with being alone it was June 27 of 2016
someone would have told me that I would
be coming back to my son being gone I
wouldn't have ever guessed it
[Music]
I don't know I don't know what kind of
just pushed him that day and I think
that's one of the hardest things not
knowing you know as a mom and if I could
have I would have done anything to keep
him here we hear about the gay kids who
are taking their lives but now it really
did happen I wasn't just someone said it
I live it it's real
[Music]
you can't sit and see a kid suffer or
see a kid talk about how they're worth
nothing and that there are only two
options is easy to live the church or to
commit suicide I've dealt with those
kind of situations with kids
[Music]
if I didn't have Jill part of me thinks
that I probably wouldn't be here right
now
are you suicide is something that I've
struggled with for a while there was a
time I even thought that my parents
would rather me die than to marry a man
and so it's something that logically I
thought made the most sense I was having
a really really really hard time and so
I was talking to a friend about it and
he said why if someone that I can put
you in contact with her name is Joan
she's a mama dragon and I had no idea
what in the world of Mama dragons were
so it's been interesting that in a space
of a couple years Jill has now become
such an integral part of my life or just
his home he's welcome here we love Shane
as a family but I think it has taken a
long time for him to really start to
realize how wonderful he is he's had to
go through a lot of dark times
it's very hard to be both openly gay and
a very active serious member of the
church you know how do I choose between
literally two parts of who I am I think
that's a challenge that lots of people
had to experience
sometimes my youngest daughter asked me
how do you go to a church that hates
your son and it's a hard question to
answer I think if I were to categorize
it I feel like I'm in a bit of a faith
crisis a little bit I pray and sometimes
I feel like you know was anybody
listening to me my relationship with
Heavenly Father and Jesus is kind of a
work in progress you know religion and
spirituality or two different things so
I really decipher between the church and
the gospel and the gospel always be part
of me the gospel of Jesus Christ is
perfect the church is imperfect even
though the gospel is perfect I look at
you know the leaders of our church today
and say well I wish they were a little
more loving and compassionate and
understanding of the experiences of LGBT
people but for me I know that being a
member of the church is where God has
called me to be
I got a card from a family in Idaho Oh
on the back it says Jill thanks for
loving accepting my son and for being
such a positive impact for good in his
life you will never know how much that
means to us that's from his mom of
course that always means a lot to me
this life is meant to live finding one
friend finding two friends I can make a
world of a difference that day will come
when you can be yourself when you have
that support system that's sheer bliss
the mama dragons mission is to help
people to see that there's hope that
they can find a community in which they
feel loved and know that if they're
doing it with me they're doing it with
other people I look forward to the day
when mama Drago's doesn't need to exist
when having an LGBTQ kid is just as
ordinary as having a kid who's
left-handed I feel like there's more
Stockton's within the walls of the
church and there's more parents who need
to know that you can love your kid I
believe that there will be a day that I
will be reunited with him if not maybe
really pissed
[Music]
you